-Our first guest tonight is
Grammy Nominated musician
please welcome back to the show,
Post Malone!
How are you, Post?
-Hey, everybody! How are you
doing, Seth, what's going in
-Not much, man.
It's been a long time.
You were here in 2017,
we didn't chat on the show then.
It's great to see you,
how are doing?
-I'm fantastic, sir. I'm jus
kinda laying low right now
And um, we had a great tim
on the show
so I appreciate you having u
back, thank you, sir.
-Uh, you are nominated
for three Grammys,
which is obviously gonna be
slightly different show
this year, but I imagine tha
was still very exciting?
-No, it's good stuff,
you know.
Sorry, we got construction going
on outside.
-Then I'm gonna jump -- I have a
construction question.
-Sure.
-You're in Utah right now,
correct?
-Yes, sir.
-So I've heard one of the things
you're building in your plac
in Utah is an underground
bunker,
is that what
the construction is right now?
-Uh, you know, it might be par
of it, you know.
We're doing
some fun stuff over here
like marble beer pong tables
but, uh.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, the bunker's coming
Things take a little bit.
But we're figuring everythin
out, you know.
-Do you feel like --
-Maybe h--
-Hopefully I can keep my Grammys
in there.
-That would be good.
Grammys in a bunkers just
feels like, I mean,
a wonderful outcome.
-That's pretty baller.
-[ Laughs ] Wait. Hey, do th
construction guys,
are they aware,
because I would imagine
a Utah construction compan
would not expect that they
would end up working on
Post Malone's home,
are they aware on who they'r
working with?
-I think so. I kind of wal
around in my, you know,
boxers all day, just around th
place and check everything out
So, I think, you know,
they know it's me.
And everybody and we just kind
hang out.
And I offer 'em beers but they
always say no, you know.
-That's good.
-I just want to party.
-I feel like that's a good tes
for your construction crew
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a test,
I just wanna have fun!
-And you are enjoying --
I have certainly read that
you're enjoying
your time in Utah.
-Mm, yes, sir, very much,
you know.
LA was just a lot, you know.
Especially working on musi
and in LA
there's always something to do
there's always some place to b
and there always, you know
people around that you --
You know, here it feels good t
be kind of, like you know,
secluded and relaxed.
And I can just kind of take my
time and, and take it easy
And work on being a better
artist, you know?
-That would definitely strik
me as one of the appeals,
but again, I read something that
made me very jealous
because I heard you were maybe
gonna build a bunk room
that could house 30 of you
friends.
I was jealous because I don'
have 30 friends.
-[ Laughs ]
-Is there really a --
is there really a --?
-I wish I didn't have
30 friends.
-[ Laughs ]
Is there a world where you'r
gonna have 30 friends
visit you at once?
-No.
But you know whenever, uh,
things go down, if they go down,
you never know who's,
who you're gonna have show u
at your front door and you'll be
like, oh well, uh...
I don't have
a place for you to stay.
But, you know,
better safe than sorry, I guess.
Get everybody a bunk
or a sleeping bag
or something like that,
you know.
-See, that's very kind of you.
That's very thoughtful.
Because I guess ultimately,
don't know if I have 30 friend
but I do feel like,
if I had a bunker,
I know of at least 30 people who
would show up.
-[ Laughs ] Right, exactly
You know,
you have to plan in advance.
-Yeah. Certainly if there's an
apocalypse you don't want to b
in that awkward situation of
you know, saying
"You know, we really
haven't talked that much
in the last 10 years.
-Yeah, no, yeah.
You're my, like, fourth cousin
third removed,
but I still love you I think, so
come on in.
-So, Post, I want to ask about
this as well,
I know that you are a believer
in the supernatural.
I -- it's not that I'm not,
just have never encountere
anything that has made me
skeptic.
But are you someone who --
I know you were
on "Ghost Hunters."
-Mm-hmm.
-And was that an experienc
that made you --
is your belief in ghosts
stronger after doing that?
-Yeah, I think, you know, afte
going on, um,
You know, going hunting with Zak
and everything
and, and all that stuff, and w
stayed at his museum in Vegas.
I love you Zak, text me.
-And so Zak, Zak gets a spot
in the bunk room,
is that what I'm hearing?
-Yeah.
Zak Bagans is definitely in here
because if we need to
fight off any demons or anything
after the apocalypse,
there's gonna be a whole bunch
of them running around, so
But, you know, it's weird
because after we opened up
this creepy, creepy dybbuk box
I got in a car accident,
I got in like almost had a plane
wreck, my house got broken into,
all that type of stuff.
But it was just,
within a months' time.
It was really, really odd stuff.
But, I've always had, like, yo
know an interest in that.
And have had experience at m
friend's house and things, but
-And UFOs as well, you have been
lucky enough to, uh, see
what you at least believe to b
a UFO, that true?
-Right. Right.
Yeah, hell yeah.
And especially here in Utah,
things are, things are creep
if you look up into the sky.
Sometimes I just go out at
like 4 am
with my night-vision goggles and
just look up at the sky
and see if we can see anything
-Do you have any neighbors
who can see you?
-Um, you know, it's weird
whenever I moved here there wa
one house across the street.
But now, I was talking to
builder the other day,
and now they're building 4
houses over there.
So, my back-up plan
is in effect immediately.
-[ Laughs ] The real estat
agents saying like,
these are these great --
these houses are great,
they have a view
of Post Malone's place.
-Right, they have no idea what I
get up to over here.
-They're like, don't be --
at night there's a man
will wander out with his
night-vision goggles.
Don't overreact to that.
-They don't know
that I'm watching them.
-[ Laughs ]